1000 flüchtlinge pro tag von belarus
diktator lukaschenko weiter nach europa
durchgewunken durch geschickt und unser
noch innenminister horst seehofer hat
jetzt im bild-interview alarm geschlagen
in so wichtigen fragen wie
grenzkontrollen migrationspolitik tritt
jetzt so eine phase ohne große handlung
ein wie sehr schränkt das die kraft des
innenministeriums ein ja sehr stark
darum hoffe ich ja dass die
verhandlungen jetzt über der
ampelkoalition in der tat noch im
dezember den kanzler wählen dann stehen
aber trotzdem dann zwei monate in denen
im grunde ist sie recht optimistisch ich
rechne es pessimistisch erbes der
kanzler gewählt ist vielleicht fünf
wochen aber wichtig wäre dass die neue
regierung bald zustande kommt denn
gerade in meinem bereich von der inneren
sicherheit bis zur migration stehen sehr
sehr große aufgaben an wir haben nicht
nur klima sondern wir haben große große
nationale und internationale probleme zu
lösen wir hatten vor zwei tagen zum
ersten mal seit vielen jahren am tag 1
über 1000 zuwanderer wenn sie das mal
auf den monat hochrechnen dann wissen
sie dass der dringende handlungsbedarf
da ich rechtes mal aufs jahr hoch sind
300.000
dringender handlungsbedarf und jetzt ist
er weiß nicht was seehofer aber claus
strunz unser bild live chef der die wall
interview geführt hat schönen guten
morgen wie glaubst du was wird jetzt
überhaupt gemacht die ampel die show
wird noch um die versucht sich gerade zu
bilden jetzt ist die situation aber da
und horst seehofer sagt an seinem
abschiedsinterview sagt ja es muss was
passieren es besteht dringender
handlungsbedarf
ja ich hab das auch gerade jetzt einmal
gebannt geguckt da sagt er unglaubliches
er sagt ja bestätigt dass diese
regierung damit auch sein ministerium
jetzt nicht mehr handlungsfähig ist die
regelung lautet wir müssen es uns noch
mal vergegenwärtigen 1 0 noch
geschäftsführende minister auch die
kanzlerin kann und darf nur noch
grundlegende entscheidungen treffen also
weit reichende entscheidungen nicht von
heute auf morgen nichts von heute auf
übermorgen
nicht mal was von heute auf nächstes
jahr sondern nur wirklich umwälzende und
das lähmt jetzt sozusagen unsere
regierung unser land ist jetzt ohne
regierung und wir setzen darauf und
müssen hoffen dass diese neue koalition
sich möglichst schnell bildet und ich
will noch mal auf diese rechnung
eingehen fünf wochen sagt horst seehofer
das glaube ich klappt nicht es gab
vielleicht vor weihnachten dann ist aber
weihnachten und es glaubt er kein bürger
dass ich dann die neue regierung
hinsetzt und diese probleme anpackt
sondern gehen alle in die
weihnachtsferien und dann ist es mitte
januar und dann ist es schon 2022 und
bis dahin geschieht in zentralen fragen
nichts und da kriege ich wirklich also
sozusagen große zweifel ob das land auf
dem richtigen weg ist wenn 1000
flüchtlinge zuwanderer pro tagen nach
deutschland kommen und niemand handelt
das ist ja wie eine einladungskarte hier
können alle herkommen jetzt ohne ticket
und ohne einlasskontrolle weil die
regierung gar nicht mehr im amt ist und
die neue regierung ist dann die hoffnung
fragezeichen ein möglicherweise grüner
bundesinnenminister naja natürlich muss
man sehen wie es so aussieht kann es ja
auch ein grüner bundesinnenminister
werden das heißt es muss dann auch erst
noch ein neuer politikansatz es quasi in
handlung verwandelt werden dass das kann
noch mal weiter drei vier fünf monate
bedeuten wenn ich jetzt ein schlepper
organisator werden schlepperbanden
chefin ein schlepper reisebüros als
zynischer weise manchmal sogar dann
würde ich doch außen kommt jetzt alle
deutschland ist nicht in der lage seine
grenzen jetzt so aufzustellen wie es
eigentlich sein müsste weil es gibt gar
kein innenminister man dass kein vorwurf
an horst seehofer der kann nichts machen
er ist entlassen worden augen komisches
war der meister aber so hat nix böses
gemacht entlassen worden weil die
legislaturperiode zu ende ist und damit
seine amtszeit wir sind jetzt in einem
gefährlichen vakuum und wer müsste
seiner ansicht nach handeln tremmel ich
glaube sie müssen sie jetzt tatsächlich
seehofer den anstoß geben hat das
gestern auch angedeutet dass es in
extremsituationen geht also wenn jetzt
noch weitere tage jeden tag 1000 oder
sogar noch mehr menschen kommen dann
wird er auf die neuen regierungsparteien
zugehen und darauf dringen dass was
geschieht und ich glaube es gibt eine
sache die man ganz ingrid jetzt machen
muss eigentlich besser heute als morgen
das ist alle relevanten
sicherheitskräfte innenministerium
polizei müsse sich zu einem grenz gipfel
mit ihren kollegen in polen
zusammenfinden und wir müssen dieses
problem doch jetzt fixen ich will noch
mal einen vergleich machen es erinnert
mich total daran dieses blöde corona
virus hat sich nicht daran gehalten dass
die gesundheitsämter öffnungszeit nahmen
diese verfluchte flut hat sich 0 dafür
interessiert dass wir weder sirenen
haben noch unsere menschen warnen können
und die menschen in not die jetzt aus
ihren ländern flüchten die nutzen ihre
chance jetzt natürlich dass dieses land
wieder nicht handeln kann und das glaube
ich muss man den bürgern einmal zu rufen
und es muss so eine art hallo wach ihr
geschäftsführende regierung ihr lahme
enten lame duck ist ja dass
amerikanische waren eine lahme enten
regierung jetzt nicht weil die alle faul
und doof wären sondern weil sie jetzt
gerade nicht anders können sie müssen
aber sie müssen die ausnahmeregelung im
notfall kann ich jetzt nutzen da gibt es
noch andere ministerien teuer schock und
was ist alles gibt zäune oder mauern
gegen flüchtlinge polen bereitet das vor
an der außengrenze nach belarus jetzt
gibt es auch durchaus sympathie in der
politik hier nach da erstmal großen
aufregung das kann man noch nicht das
darf doch nicht jetzt zum beispiel
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
der das durchaus unterstützt findet das
auch sympathie bei dir klaus daher ist
man ja dass ausgerechnet
ministerpräsident aus dem osten für
mauern ist da gibt es eigentlich nach
meinem geschichts empfinden eher darum
mauern zu überwinden als sie aufzubauen
man kann aber uns so deute ich den
ministerpräsidenten sehen wie dramatisch
die lage ist was ich dabei wieder
interessant finde ist dass wir die
anderen wieder unsere arbeit machen
lassen also sozusagen irgendwie verfolgt
deutschland in der politik wir wollen
nach möglichkeit mit dem
anstrengenden teil mit den
kritikwürdigen teil nichts zu tun haben
das sollte mal die ungarn machen jetzt
soll das die polen machen wir brauchen
doch ein bekenntnis dazu was wir
eigentlich wollen und wir wollen
menschen eine neue heimat geben die auf
der flucht sind und wo asylgründe
vorliegen wir wollen aber nicht jeden da
haben dann nach deutschland will jetzt
hast du ja gesagt horst seehofer müsse
ein zeichen geben der adia war gestern
gesagt jetzt erst mal beschäftigt eine
fahrstunde seiner frau karin hat
überhaupt keine zeit sich über
schreibers richtig also total witzig hat
ja auch sehr genau die seien aber gab
sich also sagen wir mal so ich glaube
dass ihnen das schon glaubst du wie
wahrscheinlich mit der flapsigen wie
wahrscheinlich hältst du es dass da
wirklich noch mal ein signal kommt auch
wenn es von dem müsste es ich glaube es
kann von ihm kommen wenn die lage so
bleibt und ich glaube dass er das auch
in der nötigen weise ernst nimmt weil es
nicht nur für deutschland wichtig ist
was ihm an allererster stelle wichtig
sein muss sondern politiker sind immer
ja auch ein bisschen darauf bedacht auf
ihr erbe es geht ja auch ein bisschen um
das erbe des bundesinnenministers des
mannes der für die innere sicherheit
zuständig ist und da wäre es auch für
die amtszeit von horst seehofer unschön
wenn ausgerechnet am ende vieles von dem
was er vorher einrichten konnte jetzt
wieder sozusagen verändert wird also da
ist es für wahrscheinlich dass da noch
mal einen anstoss kommt und ich hoffe
auch ehrlich gesagt ist es vielleicht
ein bisschen naiv aber ich hoffe auch
dass wenn wir darüber diskutieren und
sagen da muss jetzt was passieren dass
dieser dieser dieses hallo wach bemerkt
und gehört wird